[Music]
straight ahead on long crime daily
johnny depp versus amber heard as
against amber heard we the jury award
compensatory damages in the amount of 10
million dollars just weeks after a
verdict is handed down both sides file a
notice of appeal and
one of four former minnesota officers is
sentenced in federal court for his role
in the death of george floyd plus the
parkland school shooter penalty phase
trial i checked her vital signs for
breath and for pulse i found none
parents gave an emotional reaction as
first responders described the carnage
and later i then stuck my head out real
quickly to see what was going on
that's when i think that's when i got
grazed by the first bullet a full recap
as week one of the trial comes to a
close lawn crime daily covering court
cases from coast to coast
[Music]
welcome everyone to long crime daily i'm
your host brian buckmeyer amber heard
and johnny depp both file appeals less
than two months after a verdict is
handed down in the defamation trial
watched around the world
on june 1st a jury ruled largely in
favor of depp saying the actor was
defamed in a washington post op-ed
written by ex-wife amber hurd heard
claimed she was a survivor of domestic
abuse while depp maintained he never
physically abused her after weeks of
testimony and nearly 13 hours of
deliberations a jury awarded depp 10
million dollars in compensatory and 5
million in punitive damages heard was
awarded 2 million dollars in
compensatory damages and zero in
punitive damages over statements made by
depp's attorney last week judge penny
azkarati denied amber heard's motion for
a mistrial over juror fraud heard then
filed a notice of appeal on thursday of
this week arguing she had not been
granted a fair trial on friday depp
filed a counter appeal now working to
overturn the single count of defamation
against him
a spokesperson for heard released a
statement on her behalf that said quote
we believe the court made errors that
prevented a just and fair verdict
consistent with the first amendment we
are therefore appealing the verdict
while we realize today's filing will
ignite twitter bonfires there are steps
we need to take to ensure both fairness
and justice johnny depp's team released
a statement on friday reading in part
quote this was an overwhelmingly
positive verdict for mr depp but if miss
hurd is determined to pursue further
litigation by appealing the verdict mr
depp is filing a counter a concurrent
appeal to ensure that the full record
and all relevant legal issues are
considered by the court of appeals
joining us today is legal analyst
matthew mangino and co-host terry austin
matt the motion from heard's team
doesn't really say what the appeal
arguments are is that odd and from what
you see or what you saw of the case are
there any potential winning arguments on
appeal
well brian i don't think it's odd that
this notice of the pill doesn't have
specifics
i think what's going to happen here is
they're going to file you know
questions uh for the court to review uh
the lower court who's already denied
post-trial motions may have to uh in
fact write an opinion based on what some
of those issues are so they can form and
format uh the issues uh for the
appellate court uh you know there's
gonna be a number of issues here i mean
every objection and there were a lot of
them that we heard or there's a
potential issue for appeal a potential
heir
we also have this uh 15 number 15 juror
the mysterious juror which may certainly
be an appellate issue so i think there
are some things here uh that are going
to get the appellate court's attention
at least for review
all right well i have a part two of the
johnny depp amber herd case terry once
an appeal is filed what are the next
steps and what does depp have to do in
order to keep his win
well you know technically there's going
to be a lot of research a lot of
briefing then obviously they'll have an
argument before that appellate court
what i find most interesting though is
johnny depp did not just defend the
motion that he brought an appeal to he
filed a counter claim and so he's trying
to say that that two million dollar
verdict against him really shouldn't be
something that stays so i think we'll
see arguments on both sides i don't
think either one is going to win i think
most of the evidentiary decisions on
both sides frankly were fair and they
certainly weren't material enough to
make a difference so i think the
verdicts are probably going to stand
yeah it's going to be interesting
counter appeal though end appeal we'll
see how this continues and of course
give you updates here the law and crime
daily in political news a federal jury
finds steve bannon guilty on all
accounts for defying subpoena to appear
before the january 6 committee after
less than three hours of deliberations
jurors found bannon guilty on two counts
of contempt of congress the charges
stand from bannon's actions and fair to
act in response to the january sixth
riots when called to appear before the
january committee bannon refused citing
executive privilege from the former
president donald trump bannon acted as a
white house chief strategist and senior
counsel during trump's presidency
prosecutors argued bannon chose
allegiance to trump over compliance with
the law only two witnesses were called
and bannon's team declined to present a
defense right now bannon's sentencing is
set for october 21st each count carries
up to one year in prison plus a fine of
up to a hundred thousand dollars
in texas two men have been indicted on
federal charges in the truck smuggling
case which led to the deaths of 53
migrants omero zamaranu junior and
christian martinez were previously
charged along with two others after
dozens of dead migrants were discovered
in the trailer of an abandoned truck in
san antonio last month 50 adults and
three children were found it is believed
to be the deadliest human smuggling case
in u.s history now sumira new and
martinez face federal charges of
conspiracy to transport illegal aliens
resulting in death and transportation of
illegal aliens resulting in death among
other charges which could lead to the
life in prison or death penalty sumeri
new is the suspected driver of the
tractor trailer according to the court
documents martinez said the driver was
unaware the air conditioning unit
stopped working in the trailer and that
was the reason why the migrants died
most of those who died were from mexico
or guatemala
in celebrity news the nephew of latin
pop star ricky martin withdraws claims
he had a sexual relationship with the
singer martin was accused of new of an
in sexual relationship and had a
temporary restraining order issued
against him earlier this month
the accuser's identity was initially
protected by a domestic abuse prevention
and intervention act but the accusations
were revealed to be from the singer's 21
year old nephew dennis sanchez sanchez
says he shared a romantic relationship
with martin for seven months he claimed
after it ended martin wouldn't leave him
alone so he got a restraining order on
thursday the case was dismissed a
request from sanchez martin's lawyers
claim quote this was never anything more
than a troubled individual making false
allegations right now martin is facing
other legal troubles for his former
manager is suing him for 3 million for
alleged unpaid commissions and breach of
contract
still ahead on law and crime daily a
recap of week one in the parkland school
shooter penalty phase but first the
death of george floyd a federal sentence
is handed down to ex-minnesota officer
thomas lane
[Music]
welcome back one of the four former
minnesota officers charged in relation
to the death of george floyd is
sentenced on federal charges floyd died
two years ago in may 2020 when former
officer derek showroon knelt on his neck
for more than 90 minutes suffocating him
it was during an arrest over floyd
allegedly using a counterfeit 20 bill at
a minneapolis area grocery store chauvin
and fellow officers two tao thomas lane
and jay alexander king were indicted on
both state and federal charges after
floyd's death in december chauvin pled
guilty to violating floyd's civil rights
in february the other three officers
king lane and tau were convicted on the
same charges on thursday lane was
sentenced to two and a half years in
prison for violating floyd's rights
while floyd was on the ground lane was
holding his legs as he died
[Music]
i'll survive
as for the state cases showman has
already gone to trial where he was
convicted and sentenced to more than 20
years lane made a plea agreement for
aiding and abetting manslaughter that
sentencing is set for september and king
and tau are set to go to trial in
january
terry two and a half years the judge
went much lower than the prosecution's
request of five years and four months to
six and a half years did that seem right
to you
you know what brian i do think that was
reasonable lame was found guilty of
violating george floyd's rights by not
providing medical care but he wasn't the
one primarily responsible for floyd's
death obviously derek tobin was found
directly responsible for his death so i
think that this
sentence is obviously a reasonable one
and when you have someone who
is not really primarily responsible and
remember he was only on the force for a
few days he was the one who said maybe
you should turn george floyd over he
also had no prior complaints he also was
the one who was very much concerned
about delirium so i do think that this
is a very reasonable number and the
judge could have gone higher or lawyer
but because no one is happy with it it's
probably the right amount yeah now matt
with looking ahead lane is expected to
be sentenced in september on state
charges what do you think his defense
team will aim for as a sentence there
and which jail will he likely be in
federal or state
well brian as i understand uh the
attorney general's office in minnesota
and the defense
team have uh jointly recommended a
three-year sentence and that three-year
sentence uh if the judge goes along with
it
would
run concurrent or at the same time as
this two and a half year
federal sentence
the
agreement also provides that he will
serve his sentence in a federal prison
and it when he
when he was sentenced yesterday it's to
dilute minnesota federal prison yeah so
that kind of answered that question it
looks like they're trying to line up all
these senators that's probably why the
judge in the federal case went with the
two and a half years to be something
similar to that of the state case well
coming up on law and crime daily we head
to florida for the parkland school
shooter penalty phase trial still ahead
first responders describe the scene as a
victim's parent breaks down in the
gallery
[Music]
welcome back as week one of the parkland
school shooter penalty phase trial comes
to a close parents of victims have an
emotional reaction to first responders
testimony
17 people were killed and 17 more
injured when a then 19 year old gunman
opened fire at marjory stoneman douglas
high school in 2018. in october of last
year the shooter pled guilty to 17
counts of murder and 17 more counts of
attempted murder which prompted his case
to head straight into the penalty phase
it's now up to a broward county jury to
decide whether the shooter is sentenced
to life in prison were given the death
penalty on friday multiple law
enforcement officers took the stand to
describe their initial response to the
school
fred gruntenberg the father of the
victim jamie gruntenberg broke down in
tears as an officer described finding
her lifeless body i observed a
child dead on the ground
on the left and there was like smoke and
dust in the air
and i observe other officers a little
bit further ahead
i checked one room on the left-hand side
and then i went up to
the front
of the officers that were there they
were clearing
the kids out of the rooms um and uh
myself and another
officer went towards the front to uh
kind of
keep them covered as they were pulling
kids out i am over jamie gutenberg okay
and uh what happened you chapter any
vital signs yes i checked your vital
signs for breath and for pulse i found
none um and
uh checked several times
and then we held there for a moment and
uh officer schmidt and i heard a voice
we thought coming from the hallway okay
and what did you guys do
we cracked the door uh confirmed that
somebody in the hallway was asking for
help and we decided we were going to
move into the hallway to go get them we
moved into the hallway and walked
towards the voice which turned out to be
anthony borges
made contact with him
i was still looking down the hallway
covering in case we encountered a
subject
and the officers dragged him back to get
him into the hallway to provide medical
care
terry 17 people were injured and 17
people lost their lives that day could
some of the families that made claims
against the officials who failed to
timely respond
we know that they're already made these
civil lawsuits so what are the updates
on those
so the first case that was filed
actually was the father of metal pollock
and he filed a wrongful death suit
against a number of parties but
particularly serif deputy scott peterson
he basically claimed that peterson
failed to respond and most of the
complaint had to do with peterson but he
also sued the individuals where the
defendant lived who were taking care of
him because his parents were no longer
in the picture and he also sued mental
health centers but it turns out that
most of those suits that followed that
first suit have been settled they even
sued the fbi at the end of the day
because they were claiming that the fbi
had been warned and did not do anything
to try to stop this there was a call
made to the fbi but there was no
response to that so at this point i
think no matter what else happens
because the statute of limitations has
run it will probably be the end of most
of those suits because they've settled
now yeah matt the defense has argued
that reactions from victims families in
court could be affecting the jury so how
does the court balance the right for the
victims families to be there in court
and to express their loss with that of
the defendant's right to a fair trial
well court rooms are open to the public
and the public can come there and watch
trials and
other proceedings
particularly with regard to victims
or victims families the courtroom is
always going to be open now the judge
will admonish
spectators not uh to to make any
outbursts we saw that a family or a
couple of families that got up and left
during the trial we know somebody else
had said stop the tape
but you know only if
spectators uh begin to to make outbursts
repeatedly with the court in any way
banish a particular
person they're not going to banish
somebody because they're emotional but
they could get who's who's making
outbursts all right we'll see how it
continues to continue to follow this
case when we come back our coverage
continues in the parking school shooter
penalty phase trial as week one comes to
a close we bring you the highlights of
the trial so far
welcome back we continue our coverage
now in the parkland school shooter
penalty phase trial on monday the
prosecution presented its opening
statement the defense indicated it will
present its opening after the
prosecution calls its final witnesses
with nearly 2 000 names on the witness
list the case is expected to last for
months at the end of week one dozens of
witnesses have already taken the stand
jurors heard compelling testimony from
students and teachers who survived the
shooting one teacher described reacting
to the emergency and filtering kids out
of the school after being shot
i
pushed them all in the door i think
there was 12-ish kids
i then stuck my head out real quickly to
see what was going on
that's when i think that's when i got
grazed by the first bullet
because i got a graze on my face in this
general area and then i got another one
on my hip that i didn't find until the
next day actually
and
i tucked my head back this all happened
very quickly
and then i looked out again i saw the
shooter had the gun up and away
because he was about 25-ish feet from my
guesstimation i yelled at the kids to
run and then i took off down the hallway
and held open the first door
for the kids as they came through after
all my kids came through at least i
thought all my kids came through i put
my foot by the door to let them have
time to get down
later in the week jurors were shown
surveillance video of the gunman's last
minutes after the massacre when he
visited a mcdonald's and later bought an
icy from a subway restaurant
i mean i saw him sit down so i just was
telling him you know like this is so
chaotic you know this is crazy all these
helicopters and swat cars coming like
what do you think this could be and
um i don't remember him saying much but
he was just
head down wasn't really talking to me i
don't remember much of the conversation
but
i was doing most of the talking he asked
me for a ride
he was pretty insistent on it and i said
no
i just
i wasn't really thinking
much of it i mean i was just trying to
get home my sister wasn't answering her
phone i was
nervous i was panicked i didn't i also
had a bad
gut feeling about it do you see you
yes which one is you
the one in the green shirt or not
do you remember what you were serving
him
uh he wanted an icy mixed
it was a cherry and a blue raspberry
matt the defense decided to reserve
their opening statements till after the
prosecution is done with their case
after a week of testimony does that
sound like a smart move to you
well normally
brian i would never wave the opportunity
to have an opening statement i would
never defer it until
our
defense case
you don't want to leave a jury with the
only thing
on their mind is what the prosecution
told them what they were going to tell
them and then what they uh
ultimately told them during the course
of the case but this case is not a
normal case it's different than most
cases um and and you know maybe this
strategy will work because
the jury's going to forget those opening
statements after they've seen all this
graphic evidence and maybe it's a good
idea to open
when you present your your mitigation
but but normally i would not do that all
right well in time we'll tell us this
case continues terry the defendant's
behavior is different in surveillance
videos and then in the courtroom how do
you think that will impact the jury
you know that jury is looking for every
clue that they can find about the
defendant's behavior and whether or not
they should spare his life so they're
watching him in that video and they're
watching him in the courtroom in the
video he is nonchalant he's cavalier
he's ordering an ic he sits down he has
a casual conversation with another
student and they see that he's acting
like a normal human being now in the
courtroom he's looking as though he's
distressed he's distraught he feels bad
he wants the jury to feel for him so i
think seeing the dichotomy between the
video and what his behavior is in the
courtroom is going to work against him
so we'll see what happens at the end of
the day all right well matt terry thank
you very much as always great show and
thank you for joining us here on law and
crime daily we'll see you next time as
we discuss justice in america
[Music]
you